Salut ! Aujourd'hui, je ne vous
emmène pas durant 1 mois avec moi...
A la place, ce mois-ci,
j'ai une autre idée !
Je vous emmène 1 journée,
avec moi, non-stop.
C'est une journée type
de ce que je fais depuis le mois de janvier,
à savoir : faire du spectacle...
en faisant des vidéos...
et en faisant autre chose.
J'ai filmé ça à Bordeaux
parce qu'on était là-bas pour
un plateau avec Vérino,
que vous connaissez déjà,
avec Artus
que vous connaissez aussi,
qui est passé sur ma chaîne.
Enfin bref !
Tout commence quand je me réveille...
[Musique Générique]
Il est 10h30, je suis à l'hôtel,
et je me réveille
seulement maintenant...
Parce que je me suis couché tard
hier soir.
Déjà, parce que je me suis refais
tout le débat des présidentielles,
donc, ça durait 3h30 : je me le suis regardé
en replay avant de me coucher...
On s'éclate !
Et puis, ensuite, parce que
j'étais en spectacle hier soir.
Je crois, d'ailleurs, que c'est la date
où il y a eu le plus de Vous
au spectacle. On s'est vraiment
écaltés, c'était archi-complet !
Je vous donne les dates d'avril,
je serai :
à Mulhouse, à Senas, à Strasbourg
à la Vidéo City de Paris
le samedi !
Et j'avais dit qu'en avril je ferai
une annonce pour les gens de Nantes,
parce que les gens de Nantes,
de Vendée et de Bretagne,
ont été nombreux à dire que
je ne passais pas dans leur secteur...
Je vous ai proposé qu'on passe
la journée ensemble,
ben voici par quoi va commencer
ma journée...
Vous avez remarqué, dans les Vlogs,
en ce moment, je suis malade 1 fois par mois.
Comme j'ai un rythme soutenu,
je prends beaucoup de trains et tout ça...
[Riant de la situation]
Et là, j'ai juste tout ça
à prendre le matin...
Première étape :
Rejoindre le Diablosaure.
Et la dernière étape
de la journée,
ce sera de jouer au
Théâtre Femina.
C'est un 1200 places, à Bordeaux,
qui est magnigfique.
Et on doit tous jouer,
comme çà, 15 à 20 minutes...
Et, euh... je ne sais pas encore
ce que je dois jouer...
Ça va être un peu le leitmotiv
de cette journée
mais je ne sais pas encore
ce que je vais faire sur scène...
Je viens de recevoir un SMS
de Diablosaure.
Alors, Diablo, quand il t'envoie un SMS
c'est çà :
[Msg vocal - Voix de Diablo] Je pars déplacer
la voiture au parking. A tout de suite.
C'est super drôle, parce qu'il parle
vraiment comme un SMS !
Ça doit le saouler d'écrire,
mais il le fait à la voix,
mais il doit être persuadé que,
peut-être, ça a être retranscrit par texte...
J'en sais rien...
[Diablo] Aaah, c'est une journée qui
commence bien !
[Fab]C'est une journée qui commence bien.
Nous allons manger au restaurant :
Vatel, de Bordeaux.
Pour rejoindre l'équipe de CDiscount
et Simon Puech,
alias le Jeu Videal.
[Fab - Style "Récit dramatique"]
Il est seul. Dans le tramway.
Il repense à sa vie d'avant...
Mais il a dû fuir.
Fuir... [rires]
[Reprenant sa voix normale]
On ne sait pas trop si c'est toi qui fuit quelque chose
ou si c'est les gens qui te fuient,
En tout cas, il y a une fuite...
[Diablo] Vers l'au-delà.
[Fab] Vers l'au-delà.
Et... même un petit peu après...
[Diablo] Ouais !
[Fab] C'est le Diablosaure.
[Diablo] J'voudrais pas dire, mais il y a
de la relance sur la gelée de coings...
[Fab] On a un Simon Puech,
alias le Jeu Videal,
Et il y a du CDiscount
par là...
Vous étiez un peu dans la vidéo
du mois dernier,
mais en meubles...
Il y a Aurore, de CDiscount,
qui se fout de moi,
parce que j'ai commandé, à l'apéro,
un allongé.
Mais vous, vous avez vu,
ce matin.
Ce n'était pas évident, pour moi,
de prendre un café.
Alors, je prends un allongé
à l'apéro.
Tu vois ? Regarde.
Il arrive. Il arrive.
[Diablo] Le café !
Et l'allongé pour monsieur en face.
Je te fais des petits travelings
des familles, mon pote...
[Rires]
[Diablo - à la serveuse] Merci.
[Fab] Si tu ne connais pas Le Jeu Videal,
il faut que tu t'abonnes.
[Fab] Merci beaucoup.
[Simon] Je rends.
Je viens de regarder la fin d'un film,
là, dans le lit,
et je croyais que j'allais m'endormir,
je regardais la fin de
Waterworld.
J'ai la flemme !
C'est ça aussi, parfois,
une journée. J'ai la flemme.
Bon. Je n'ai pas filmé, là,
ce que je venais de faire,
parce que, juste avant de regarder
le film, je répondais à des mails sur l'ordi ;
Je regardais un peu
les commentaires aussi,
de la vidéo d'hier.
Le numéro du prénom.
En fait, je voulais peut-être faire
mon numéro avec Pi ;
ce qui sont venus voir
le spectacle le connaissent ;
Mais j'ai peur que sur une soirée
où j'ai peu de temps sur scène,
en tout cas, où je ne joue pas
mon spectacle en entier,
soit un peu trop brutal...
[Rires]
de dire aux gens :
Hé salut...
ça vous dit d'apprendre Pi par coeur ?
Bon, peut-être que ça se passerait bien,
mais je ne sais pas si j'aurais
les "cojones" de...
d'attaquer, comme ça,
un plateau avec ça.
C'est un numéro que je
n'ai jamais isolé encore.
Donc je vais voir.
Je crois que je déciderai sur place.
Je me suis dit que ça serait
peut-être intéressant,
comme, d'habitude, on fait
un mois complet,
de faire une journée.
Mais, une journée où je suis malade
encore une fois...
C'est plein d'énergie...
[Diablo] Alors, maintenant que j'ai compris,
hein, tu vas pouvoir euh...
je te fais des SMS, mais...
des pages entières !
[Fab] Ah ! Je ne les ai pas vu !
Parce que je lui ai dit, forcément, pour les sms...
Alors là, il me fait des pages de sms.
[Son téléphone sonne]
Tiens, réponds, c'est Joachim.
[Diablo] Allô, restaurant de la folle crevette
j'écoute !
En première partie de l'Inglorious,
Franck Michaël,
en concert AVEC ses musiciens.
[Patrick] Pourquoi t'as changé d'affiche ?
[Fab] Non, ça a toujours été celle-ci...
Ah ! Mais ça c'est pour
le rodage...
[Pat] Ah, mais oui !
[Fab] Parce qu'après, on mettra
toutes les lettres.
Mais là, c'est une manière de dire que,
pour l'instant, je suis juste à A,B,C,D...
tu vois, c'est un rodage...
[Pat] Tu joues de la guitare toi ?
[Fab] Ouais ! Mais non, c'est...
Joachim ça, derrière.
C'est Joachim et sa guitare.
Toi tu passes pas des portes
dérobées, Patrick ?!
[Pat] Oui.
[Fab] Et oui...
[Pat] Qui a été dérobée d'ailleurs...
[Fab] Il n'y a plus de porte du tout.
[Diablo] Bonjour, je suis avec Gad Elmaleh
et Wasmer.
[Pat - A l'interphone] Euh... Bonjour,
je suis avec Fabien Olicard,
Patrick Chanfray, pour
l'Inglorious Comedy Club.
[Voix interphone] Vous pouvez entrer par
l'entrée des artistes qui est par le garage.
[Musique]
Alors là, on fait un bon dans le temps
parce qu'on est le 1er Avril.
J'étais en train de monter
tranquillement la vidéo qui sort aujourd'hui
et, il me manque des rushes.
Je ne sais pas où ils sont.
Comme vous voyez,
je suis toujours en tournée
donc, je ne peux pas retourner
une vidéo ce matin
l'écrire, la tourner et la monter,
donc je vais mettre celle-ci
quand même.
Il me reste encore une petit peu
de suite, mais il me manque
plein de choses entre 17h et 23h...
J'avais fait un interview avec
une chaîne Youtube,
j'avais fait un interview aussi,
également, pour France 3
il y avait tous les passages dans les loges
où on faisait les cons avec tout le monde...
Bref... Je pense que je ne les
ai pas du tout,
j'ai encore 2, 3 rushes qui me
restent dans mon téléphone
donc là, je vais vous les monter,
je vais vous les mettre après ;
Mais c'est pour vous expliquer
qu'il va y avoir ce bug temporel
et croyez moi bien,
je suis le premier dégouté.
[Musique spectacle - Volume très élevé]
[Vérino] Aaah ! Bonsoir le Femina !
Bonsoir, merci beaucoup
pour cet accueil.
Je m'appelle Vérino, je ne suis pas un acteur
mais présentateur de l'Inglorious Comedy Club...
Ce soir, vous l'avez vu, il y a des artistes
de dingue qui viennent jouer.
Enfin... y'a des artistes de dingue
qu'on a mis sur l'affiche...
[Rires du public]
On n'est pas cons, évidemment...
On a annoncé Arthus, Mathieu Madénian,
Fabien Olicard, Patrick Chanfray,
Aymeric Lompret...
Mais évidemment ils n'étaient pas dispos...
[Rires]
Vous vous êtes tellement fait
baiser les gars...
[Rires]
A la place, on a
Michel Robinoux
[Rires]
Qui est un jeune artiste talentueux.
Qui est turc !
Et qui joue...
dans sa langue natale.
[Rires]
Je suis sûr que dans la salle
il y en a qui font :
"Tu crois que c'est vrai ?"
[Rires]
Il est minuit. On a fini les dédicaces
et maintenant on va manger
dans ce magnifique restaurant,
n'est-ce pas ?
Vous pouvez dire des trucs drôles ?
C'est pour une vidéo.
[Vérino] Euh... là...euh...                        Ouais, c'est ça !
[Joe] Tu demandes aux mauvaises personnes !
[Fab] Ah mer.., Joe Brami !
Je ne vous l'ai pas présenté !
[Fab] Joe Bramiiiiiiii
[Joe] Oui c'est bien lui.
On dit ça, souvent...
[Vérino] Le mec a un jingle !
[Arthus] Il va le couper au montage.
[Fab] Ah, peut-être pas, parce que,
maintenant que tu as dit ça, ça devient drôle.
[Arthus] Tu vas le couper au montage.
[Brouhaha]
[Pat] Je goûte.  C'est pour une copine.
C'est une copine qui est partie
aux toilettes, qui...
[Fab] Est-ce que je peux essayer d'avoir
quelqu'un qui discute avec Patrick Chanfray ?
[Pat] Bien sûr.
[Fab] Juste pour voir ce que ça donne.
[Joe] Et du coup, la tondeuse à gazon...
[Pat] Oui ?
[Joe] On en a fait quoi ?
[Pat] Alors c'est simple. On l'a vendue.
[Fou rire de Joe]
[Pat] On était 3. Je suis parti, il y avait un copain,
il est parti, il était en bateau...
[Joe] Celui que tu m'as dit...
Qu'il aimait bien les voyages en Australie...
[Joe] Qui, au final, est parti au "Megaway"
[Joe] Pardon ?
[Pat] Il arrive ! Je te le donne en mille...
[Joe] Il est là !
[Pat]J'ai envie de parler très fort,
pour avoir du charisme.
[Rires]
[Corneille - Avec un accent africain exagéré]
Je ne comprends pas !
[Joe] Oh là là ! Alors ça c'est un raciste !
[Pat] C'est un copain raciste ?
[Joe] C'est un raciste.
[Rires]
[Fab] C'est Michel Leeb !
[Eclats de rire]
[Pat]Il est pas bien ?
Avec 25 kilos de moins, Magloire ?
[Eclats de rire]
[Pat] Regarde, ça c'est une très très bonne vanne...
Une corneille de pain ...
[Corneille] Merci !
[Rires]
[Pat] Hop ! Illustration...
On s'est couché tard.
Très tard.
Je n'ai pas filmé les dernières
minutes à l'hôtel...
Et je pense qu'on s'en passe très bien...
Le prochain Vlog sera le 1er mai.
Vous avez bien compris,
c'est le premier de chaque mois.
J'essayerai encore de trouver
un angle différent.
Mais vous pouvez aussi m'en
proposer un, dans les commentaires,
me dire qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
sur le vlog, sachant que j'ai 1 mois pour le faire.
C'était assez marrant de vous montrer
tout ça de l'intérieur,
d'ailleurs, si ça vous a plu :
N'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce.
Et, comme d'habitude, vous pouvez
vous abonner à la chaîne,
vous pourrez regarder la dernière
vidéo que j'avais faite,
et puis moi, je vous donne rendez-vous
très bientôt,
ce sera mardi ou mercredi,
CIAO !
[Musique du générique de fin]